the brain. Each time you think or feel, or do several involuntary actions
The hundred million neurons in your skull manage to transmit electrical signals and carry messages between them,
Problem in the end, you! And everything is done
It is the most complex and necessary organ in the body. It represents the center of the nervous system in all vertebrates.
But what if you think and feel it
Not just under the control of the brain and the central nervous system, but another brain
Did not you learn about it?
The brain uses the vagus nerve to connect and connect to many parts of the body
Including vocal cords, heart, lungs and most of the digestive tract.
This nerve is also used to carry messages (fight or escape) which illustrate
You may not experience tremors, rapid heartbeat, shortness of breath, and pain in your stomach when you are very anxious.
But while this WAN sends signals
Consistently from the brain to the rest of the body, the researchers noted that 80-90% of nerve fibers
In the intestinal nervous system is actually moving from the intestine to the brain.
In fact: the intestinal nervous system which consists of a wide network of neurons
Which control your entire digestive tract from the esophagus to the anus
You do not need the brain at all. When the vaginal nerve is cut off, the intestinal nervous system
Able to regulate and direct his reflexes of digestion, because he possesses
A tangled group of neurons. It is your second brain, and it controls you
More than you can imagine.
From the perspective of evolution, before the modern protocols of food safety, were our choices
Great revolves around food. Is it safe? Does it cause my illness? Will he give me energy?
This is why we need a direct line of communication between the intestine and the brain.
For example: fat and sugars are good sources of body energy, so we have developed mechanisms
Let the brain alert the neurotransmitters dopamine (feeling happy) when we eat
Food is high in fat and sugars, which makes us want it constantly.
You will become more interested in the intestinal nervous system when you realize that
The bacteria in your bowels produce more than 50 percent of your body's dopamine
Ninety percent of serotonin, the two neurotransmitters that have a severe effect on mood, are happy and happy.
These bacteria manipulate their desires and eating habits to ensure their survival.
Your diet determines which bacteria will grow, and as a result, the bacteria that thrive
In your bowels you can send signals to your brain through the vagus nerve to keep you eating
The food they love. For this reason, some scientists have proposed probiotics,
Or the cultivation of fecal spores (from a healthy donor) may be effective solutions in the treatment of over-eating, disposal
Of some bacteria that generate a strong desire for foods rich in fats and sugars.
In fact, current research of the intestine shows healthy microbes as a strong predictor
Mental and mental health. Mice that are fed in sterile environments without the presence of bacteria
Is characterized by social features similar to those seen in humans with autism
When the researchers studied their brains they found important changes
At serotonin levels and a special protein associated with learning and memory formation.
But after feeding mice with probiotics to help them develop healthy microbes
The symptoms subsided.
In a 30-day study, people who ate a protein containing probiotics were compared to a decrease in anxiety
And depression compared to those who consumed milk does not contain bacteria.
Another study found that mice fed a particular type of bacteria had a lower level of stress hormones
In her blood, she performed better in learning and memory tests. But when
Researchers cut the vagus nerve, all these improvements disappeared, and the intestines returned to dominate
On her emotions.
Studies have shown that vaginal nerve stimulation at different frequencies, by implantation
A small regimen may help patients with treatment-resistant depression mimic
Vaginal nerve activity for someone with healthy intestines.
The primary role of the intestines here does not end
Given that large social groups increase the likelihood of gene transmission (for both our genes and bacteria)
Researchers now believe that the mechanism of action of microbes partly promotes positive social behaviors.
Healthy intestinal bacteria may lead to higher resilience to negative emotions than others
Making you more tolerant and gives you a better ability to build strong social connections
We improve your chances of having children.
All thanks to your second brain!
Translating team translating translate autrjim @